these are grace malanez last hours
Auckland city center on the 1st of
December last year the eve of her 22nd
birthday she takes a picture of the
Christmas tree and sends it to her
parents back in the UK grace Mullane was
travelling in New Zealand as part of her
round-the-world trip after finishing
University back home she'd arranged a
date on tinder the dating app here she
meets the man now accused of her murder
the pair first go to a burger bar they
ordered drinks find a table an hour
later shortly after 7:00 p.m. they go on
to another bar here they find a smaller
table the accused who can't be named for
legal reasons puts his hand behind
Grace's head and they kiss for the first
time they continued to drink heavily
at one point miss Mullane messaged a
friend back home she said about the
defendant literally I click with him so
well a friend encouraged her to pursue
it according to a statement read out in
court today miss Mullane replied I will
let you know what happens tomorrow that
message never came at 9:37 p.m. the
couple leave the bar it's only a short
walk to the city life hotel where
they're caught on CCTV three minutes
later they take the lift to the 3rd
floor this is the last moment miss
Mullane is seen alive ms Mullane died by
strangulation the prosecution says it
was murder the defense says it was the
result of a consensual sex act gone
wrong these photographs taken by police
and shown to the jury today show the
hotel room afterwards the white
substance on the floor is luminol used
to detect traces of blood the haunting
images of mr. malanez last movements
tell part of the story of that night but
what happened behind the closed door of
the hotel room where there were no
cameras is the subject of this trial
which continues Tom Cheshire Sky News